Ivik:
..har nogle spørgsmål. Hvad synes du er godt ved designet? bare at løse..
Ole:
Altså Designet det er let og overskueligt. Det er simpelt sprog. Det er engelsk. Ja, vi er danskere, men lad det være hvad det være vil.
Det er overskueligt hernede i bunden også, det synes jeg det er fint.
*Peger på timeline*
Der er ikke...
Ole:
Nej, jeg synes det er lækkert.
Ivik:
Ja, så du synes.. Fordi det vil jo nemlig være mit andet spørgsmål. Er der noget som du kan se som du synes ville skulle være bedre, eller noget du synes der kunne være bedre?
Ole:
Rent design mæssigt?
Ivik:
Ja.
Ole:
*uforståelige ord*
Der syntes jeg den er fuldstændning som den skal være.
Ivik:
Okay, så det er også tydeligt for dig med farverne og sådan noget?
Ole:
Altså det er det eneste der var..  og det er en holdning ude i virksomheden..
Når jeg har et møde med Mia, Mia han booker mødelokale. Der har man to muligheder, synes jeg.
Ole:
Den ene er, hvem er det med? Det er en holdning. fordi har du mange mødelokaler, og konkurenten skal ind i det modsatte lokale, så vi kan se at kondurenten sidder i det andet mødelokale.
Nogle virksomheder vil måske gerne have det, andre vil ikke.
Ole:
Der er møde og deltager.
Og så Mia er arrangør, deltagerne er neden under, evt inden vi får approved.
Marco:
Så det vil du have vist på skærmen?
Ole:
Nogle kan lide det.
Ivik:
Okay, men det er faktisk godt at du lige nævner det, fordi det har også været et...
Ole:
Men det skal være en option.
Ivik:
Ja, det er super.
Ole:
Jeg ved jeg ikke om det gav mening det jeg sagde.
Ivik:
Det gjorde det.
Patrick:
Helt klart.
Ivik:
Jamen, det var faktisk.. Det var det.
Ole:
Og så lige et sidste input til jer, det er, at I ved godt at der er Bluetooth i sådan en her ikke?
Ivik:
Ja.
Ole:
Hvorfor har vi så ikke en Bluetooth presence sensor på bordet, der vil mærke om jeg er inde i mødelokalet, som så ændrer mit møde.
Patrick:
Det har vi også snakket om. Det med QR-koderne er faktisk en af de ting, vi har talt meget om.
Men vi blev ind i om at bruge QR-approachen til prototypen. Om vi gør det i praksis, det er så en anden snak.
Ole:
Det ville jeg ikke gøre, fordi nu kan vi se at vi sidder med to iPhones herinde.
Vi skulle lave et sponsorat til en kollega.
Ole:
Jeg kunne scanne den. Den anden kollega kunne ikke scanne QR-koden.
Ivik:
Okay, det er faktisk..
Ole:
Og det var en android og en iPhone.
Hvor selvfølgelig iPhone den virkede.
Marco:
Var det fordi den ikke havde en scanner?
Ole:
Den ville bare ikke læse den.. Nej den *utydeligt*.
Apple har jo en fordel i at den har jo QR-kode scanneren indbygget i kameraet.
Ole:
Og den fortolker det.
Ivik:
Ja.
Ole:
Det har dyre androids også.
Men ham der kommer med sin.. Ikke for at forklejne mig under at bruge huawei på den måde.
Ole:
Men kommer du med en billig Samsung A32 kamera?
Eller telefon, der er QR-koderne.. eller QR-kameraet, ikke enabled.
Ivik:
Nå, okay.
Ole:
Det er kun et fib, fordi det har vi bare set.
Ivik:
Det er faktisk godt feedback.
Patrick:
Ja, virkelig.
Ivik:
Det er faktisk en ting, vi har haft oppe at vende, hvordan vi vil gøre.
Ole:
Min bruger liste.
Hvor kommer den fra?
Patrick:
Vores plan, det var at gøre lidt ligesom i Outlook.
Det var så en anden ting, vi faktisk havde talt en del om.
Patrick:
Det var det her med, at okay, skal de her tablets, du ved, skal du bare kunne inviterere alle, du ved.
Og så vil de formentligt fungere igennem Outlook.
Patrick:
Og den vil så tage det ud fra den tenant, den er sat op efter, hvis det giver mening.
Ole:
Så hosten på mødet skal være en fra tenanten.
Patrick:
Ja, det var det vi havde tænkt.
Ole:
Hvad vil du gøre på Google?
Patrick:
Google har vi ikke tænkt os at understøtte som udgangspunkt.
Ole:
Ja, det er fair. Det er superfint.
Ivik:
Ja, indtil videre så holder vi os bare til..
Patrick:
Til Outlook.
Ole:
Så har vi jo et kontor fællesskab, som den dykning her. Vi er tre virksomheder. vil vi kunne benytte dem.
Ivik:
Det er også planen, vi har snakket om at lave det..
Ole:
Nu udfordrer jeg jer bare.
Patrick:
Ja, selvfølgelig.
Ivik:
Ja, det er super, men jeg tror, vi har snakket om, om det kunne være muligt at lave grupper, hvor man ligesom inkluderer begge virksomheder i de her grupper.
Og så ville det så være tilgængeligt, når du så som host går ind og siger, okay, jeg er egentlig en del af de her grupper.
Ivik:
Så når jeg skal ind og vælge den drop down, hvor alle.. hvad hedder det? alle med.. eller dem, man vil invitere, de er på, så ville de fremgå på listen.
Men der er også nogle andre spørgsmål, men det er fordi hvad så hvis du skal have et møde med 30? så vil du nok alligevel ikke gå ind og gøre det fra tableten.
Ivik:
Så vil du nok gøre det fra computeren, eller i hvert fald via Outlook.
Ole:
I mit møde.. Nu modtog jeg jo en møde indkaldelse fra jer af.
Fremgår mit gæstenet og mit SSID og mit password til gæstenettet i den møde indkaldelse?
Patrick:
Nej det vil det bestemt ikke gøre.
Ole:
Det syntes jeg jo gerne jeg vil.
Patrick:
Okay.
Ole:
Så når jeg har eksterne gæster på, så har de det, så har de fået det vist.
Ivik:
Det kunne vi godt tænke på.
Marco:
Hvor vil du have det vist siger du?
Ole:
I min møde indkaldelse.
Når jeg nu har en ekstern bruger på. Jeg ved godt hvad det hedder.
Ole:
Men når jeg så inviterer en gæst med ind til det her møde, for det gør jeg jo inde fra min Outlook.
Var det ikke rart at vi fortalte den bruger at gæste-net det hed internet, og koden den er password, eller omvendt?
Patrick:
Jo, det er også en god pointe, faktisk.
Ole:
Så kan du bare kigge i din telefon, for det står der.
Velkommen til, vi ser frem til at mødes.
Ole:
Bla bla bla.
Ivik:
Det er faktisk en superfin..
Ole:
vores gæste-net er sådan, hvor password til gæste-net er sådan.
Patrick:
Det er en rigtig god pointe.
Det løser meget med det med gæsten.
Patrick:
Vi har talt om hvordan i alverden vi skulle håndtere gæster.
Ivik:
Fra vores rapport synspunkt, så løser det også det problem, at vi skal finde en måde at argumentere for, hvor vi adskiller os fra almindelige produkter.
Og det der, det vil jo være et enormt.
Ivik:
Det er en simpel ting, men det er faktisk en fed feature at have.
I har jo gæste-net tilgængeligt.
Ole:
Vi har jo..
Når ved jeg, jeg trækker den lidt langt ud.
Ivik:
Nej, det er fint.
Ole:
Der er low power Bluetooth i dem her.
I din telefon, det er der også i den der.
*peger på telefonen vi optager med*
Ole:
Det vil sige, jeg kan trække via mine wifi informationer.
Kan jeg jo trække dit Bluetooth ID.
Ole:
Det er faktisk den presence du nu har.
Når nu du forlader mødet kl. 14:30, så kan du jo godt sige, tak for mødet.
Ivik:
Nå ja..
Og så glemme at end meeting.
Ole:
Ja, end meeting, og så kan du eventuelt også vælge, og skifte koden på gæste-nettet, hvis man vil det.
Patrick:
Ja, det går meget ud i det her med presence og sådan noget.
Det er faktisk en meget interessant vinkel syntes jeg, som vi helt klart skal undersøge.
Ole:
Presence er alt, fordi det er convenience.
Patrick:
Præcis.
Det vil også lægge rigtig godt op af vores problemformulering, 100p.
Ivik:
Det vil lægge sindssygt godt op, og det vil gøre vores rapport mere interessant også, fordi så har vi rent faktisk noget..
Vi er ikke kommet så langt med selve rapport delen af det, men lige nu, der hænger meget af det på interaktionsdelen af det, og det er også okay, men det er ikke lige så spændende som det der presence.
Ole:
Den er meget straight forward interaktionen, men for folk der har..
Okay, nu har jeg er også 30 års plus..
Ole:
Ja, det var før at de to blev født.
Men jeg har prøvet det i mange år ikke også, men jeg har også ting, som jeg siger.
Ole:
Det mangler vi.
Interne møder.
Ole:
Jamen du kommer ind, du har din presence, du har din telefon med, du har en bluetooth receiver.
Den sætter din fastnet telefon i mødetilstand.
Ivik:
Ja.
Ole:
Rent API mæssigt kan det lade sig gøre?
Hvem vil i undersøge, jamen de kan ikke se telefonsystem.
Ole:
Altså, online systemet.
Ivik:
Det skal vi have undersøgt.
Ole:
Det er igen presence.
Det er det her med.. Nu er I ikke så ramte endnu, men når Mia og jeg sidder i møder ikke også. Der er altid en af os, der har glemt at slå telefonen fra.
Patrick:
Ja, det giver god mening.
Ole:
Det er fucking irriterende.
Og det er pinligt. Du sidder med en kunde, *uforståeligt* altså herregud. Man kan bare tage den.
Ole:
Men det er at sidde herinde som host på et møde og din telefon begynder at ringe.
Vi ved jo godt vi skal slå den fra.
Ivik:
Ja.
Det giver mening.
Ole:
Nå.. I skal nok komme langt med den der. Den er fin.
Kan jeg bestille catering?
Ivik:
Det er også en feature, vi snakkede om at implementere.
Patrick:
Du må vi se hvor langt vi når med den, men det er helt klart noget der har været op.
Ole:
Catering er jo en.. en..
Ivik:
En nice to have.
Ole:
Ja, det er det.
Det er det.
Ole:
Så ellers er der sku ikke...
Og er det en overblikskærm til receptionen?
Ivik:
Det kommer der også til at være..
Patrick:
Det har vi også talt om ja.
Det er i hvert fald planen.
Ivik:
Tak for det.
Patrick:
Tusind tak for det.